SPEAKER: In this episode
of "BigQuery Spotlight,"
we're going to dive deep
into how to ask a question
or run a query in BigQuery.
Running queries is one of
the most fundamental parts
of discovering insights
from your data.
Today's question--
what is the best jersey
number you should choose
in order to improve
your basketball game?
Stay tuned and find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
It's no surprise
that big data has
made its way into the world
of professional sports.
Teams at every
level are starting
to gather, process,
and analyze data
so that they can get the
most out of their players
and find a competitive
edge in the game.
To see how this would
work, let's check out
the NCAA basketball public
data set available in BigQuery.
The data set contains
play-by-play data
for several years'
worth of games.
You can get information like
fouls, free throws, scores,
player numbers, timeouts,
basically as much data
as the pros have.
So let's see if we can use
this data for today's question
and determine which
jersey number is the best
three-point shooter.
If you want to
follow along, click
on the link in the
description below
to set up your own
BigQuery sandbox
where you can analyze data
without needing a credit card.
Once you're in the
BigQuery sandbox,
head over to the Google
Cloud Marketplace
by clicking on Add Data
and then Explore Data Sets.
Search for the NCAA
basketball and click
to launch the data set
in the BigQuery UI.
The NCAA basketball data set has
a number of different tables.
Clicking on the
play-by-play table,
you can first view
the table details,
which indicates that
there are over four
million rows of events.
That's a lot of basketball data.
Check the table
schema, and you'll
see each column or field of
data that's available for each
of those events.
But first, let's look at
what those events are.
You can start to
explore the data
by clicking on the
Preview tab to view
a few rows of sample data.
But to get a more comprehensive
list of all the event
types, the best way to
find out is to run a query.
Click Query Table
and a blank query
will appear in the editor with
a table reference pre-populated.
Before we write our query,
it's important to know
that the language used to
communicate with BigQuery
is SQL, or Structured
Query Language.
SQL is also the
standard language
for communicating with
relational databases.
BigQuery is ANSI SQL compliant,
so experienced practitioners
will hit the ground running.
Don't worry if
you're not SQL savvy.
There are plenty of resources
for learning or brushing
up on your SQL skills just
a quick web search away.
So now, let's copy
in a SQL query
to explore the event types.
The key command in SQL
for retrieving data
is SELECT, which
we'll use to pull
in a list of all of the
different event types
and number of occurrences
from the play-by-play table.
Notice that the table reference
is in the format of the GCP
project name, then
data set name,
then table name,
separated by dots
and enclosed with back
ticks, not quotes.
We'll select all of the event
types and group the results
so that we can get the
count of each event.
Once the SQL query is written,
click on the green check mark
on the right-hand
side of the window
to open the query validator.
A green check mark
means the query is valid
and will show the
estimated amount of data
that the query will
process when you run it.
If the query is invalid, a
red exclamation point icon
is displayed.
You can click on it
and get some guidance
on how to correct the problem.
Click Run and
BigQuery gets to work.
After the query
execution is complete,
the query service
displays the results
as a table in the web UI.
You can see that the
Event Type column has
both three point made and
three point miss events.
Now we can write
a new query which
selects the jersey number
for each play-by-play event
and then uses the
Event Types column
to determine the
three point field goal
accuracy for each jersey number.
Click Run and then in less than
a second we have the answer.
Looks like number 45 sinks
the highest percentage
of their three-pointer attempts.
Of course, buying a
new jersey doesn't
make you a better
basketball player, right?
An important note-- we can
see that the table we queried
has three gigabytes of data.
But BigQuery only read the
columns needed and therefore
just processed 78
megabytes of data.
Well, basketball
enthusiasts out there,
try out the NCAA
data set for yourself
and ask questions to
discover what you might
be able to do to up your game.
If you want to learn
more about BigQuery,
check out the rest
of our playlist.
And don't forget to
subscribe to our channel
on YouTube for
other great content.
Look out for the next episode
of "BigQuery Spotlight."
And remember, stay curious.
[MUSIC PLAYING]